petition sitting on the floor and more
than 20 democrats signing a letter back
in september
who said if pelosi did nothing they
would sign it it still
has not moved forward but again more
than 40 times
democrats have voted against since
summer any coveted relief that
the republicans have been able to put on
the floor now i've been working closely
with president trump
secretary mnuchin and leader mcconnell
on the relief package that
senator mcconnell introduced this week
it delivers real support for those who
need it
small businesses schools and americans
who lost their jobs
it will also ensure our vaccines reach
every american
who wants it starting with the very most
vulnerable individuals
we have to get to work on this we have
to get it done
but working is something that this
majority has not a good record on doing
just look at the floor schedule this
week democrats have focused on cats and
cannabis
but not uncovered you'd think after a
humiliating defeat at the ballot box
this year that democrats didn't defeat
one republican incumbent of the 27
most vulnerable races republicans won
them all
that democrats would get to the picture
that the americans are demanding
demanding some action on these issues
certainly doesn't appear that in the
next congress anything will change
yesterday the democrats uh released next
year's
house schedule the average number of
days working in the first session
of the past four congresses have been
134 days
you would think with all the challenges
that this country has
that we probably maybe even work at
least more
or at the very least that same amount of
time
nope democrats think congress needs a 25
percent reduction
yes you don't even have to show up for
work 60 democrats yesterday or one-third
of them
didn't show up for work just voted by
proxy and still got paid
and now they find out they don't even
have to work as much as they did before
congress is before a 25 reduction with
only scheduled 101 days
it will probably become the laziest
congress
we have ever had with that let's open it
up for questions
yes ma'am uh so the democrat in iowa's
uh second congressional race she expects
to be uh filing a petition
uh that announced that she will uh
become at least under the
the congressional uh right in front of
me
should bomb administration is the wrong
place to go if you have these challenges
you should go to court
why would she avoid going to court this
has already been through a recount the
recount has finished
uh the republican marian miller meeks
is the winner and i expect her to be
seated come january
but if the speaker does take it up and
and if the committee
does take it up but we see something
similar that we saw in 1985
where the bloody eight of indiana where
were power corrupts absolutely where
they took away the voice of the american
public who voted for an individual
and the democrats sitting in the house
decided who won and lost
let's hope it does not come to that that
should never return itself
ever in this country again can you take
the attorney generalized word that there
was no white spread voter fraud that
would have
changed the outcome of the election i'm
sorry when did the attorney sorry
we continue to work on the ndaa we know
that we will get an nda done
as we've done for the last 60 years but
we also know that section 230
of what has happened what i've stated
back in october
it needs to be repealed these uh
technology companies are not acting in
the manner of why 230 was created to
give them
protections if they want to pick and
choose what goes on and we see on a
daily basis they don't need that
protection any longer
yes sir joe biden says that on his first
day in office
he'll use title ix to give transgender
students access to sports bathrooms
and locker rooms in accordance with
their gender identity uh in all
federally funded schools do you think he
has the power to unilaterally do that
and do you
do you agree with that let's wait uh
until who's sworn in and we could
discuss that yes
coping relief i mean give us a timeline
when do you think it needs to be done
mcconnell sounded relatively optimistic
this morning schumer
do you do you have a i mean the
government runs out of money next week
so yeah i mean we have december 11th so
you have a
date um that's government funding though
that's not covet
for too long pelosi is used just just
for a political game
harming the economy picking individuals
to harm simply for the fact that she
wanted an outcome to an election the
election is over
so i'm more optimistic now that we can
get something done
but unfortunately more people are
hurting 40 times the democrats had an
opportunity that they voted no on
working with president trump with
mnuchin and with mcconnell
um i feel we've got a better opportunity
now than at any time
um i thank those members on the
democratic side who said they would sign
a discharge petition
if they would sign that discharge
petition i bet you would get a covet
bill that day
do you um on government funding do you
foresee an omnibus coming together
do you think it will be a cr at this
point
um i can see how we could have an
omnibus i could also see how
democrats can play a game and make it a
cr which is not beneficial to the nation
cost is more in the long run i'd like to
see an omnibus get done
yes on the 900 billion bipartisan
proposal that came out earlier this week
what are your thoughts on that and is
there any concern that if republicans
don't
step forward a little bit on this
compromise proposal that they might get
backlash
that you guys aimed at democrats for not
accepting the
problems republicans only goal is to get
a bill done
we'll work with anyone who wants to work
with it we've watched nancy pelosi
every time we've done a bill from the
cares act and others
to stop it she's been successful in
stopping covid
relief throughout the entire summer even
though she said
the house would not leave until we got a
bill done we've watched him vote 40
times against it
republicans will always work together to
find common ground
especially with americans hurting the
way they are just as we've done
all summer long and i'm more hopeful
today than i was in the past
that we can get it done because many
people are finally telling nancy pelosi
in her own party that she has been wrong
to hurt those who are unemployed the
small businesses that are shuddering
every day you know not every business
can be named the french laundry
and people will just go to it small
businesses are now shutting down
so to be clear are you still considering
the 900
to be clear we have a proposal out there
right now that i think we can work and
work towards
the 900 proposal i know they put out
there but i think what has been working
on right now with the
white house with mnuchin with mcconnell
and the senate the other side
is really the starting point and where
we'll probably end up last question
yeah can you clarify that point a little
bit of you talk that you've been working
with the white house on this
do you view that mnuchin mcconnell
framework that we've all seen now as
a starting point for negotiations or
sort of no this is the offer
no no look we want it we want to get a
bill done
at the same time we've been trying to
talk with the speaker
um i think she is becoming more open
than she has in the past um hopefully
that she's viewing what is going on
across the country
the pain that is happening you know the
speaker
a num a number of weeks ago said doing
nothing is better than doing something
she's probably the only person in this
country that believes that
i hope she finally changed her belief on
that doing nothing
is not better than doing something that
means
nobody gets help and i think people have
been hurt too long
businesses have been shut down
permanently people have lost their jobs
you can walk anywhere in this country
you can see that but you can also tell
exactly the person that has caused it
the speaker of this house has denied the
ability
to help go to the american public simply
because
she wanted to determine something would
happen in an election to harm president
trump and him getting reelected
what has happened is american people are
hurting
and that has got to stop thank you all
very much hope you have a good weekend